[Music]
baby wants to choose different maybe one
I would have been like oh my god what am
I gonna do it maybe to Mike I got my
pump bag I got my clock oh and I gotta
be picking up from school in like three
hours I gotta go I gotta go like you
were a little bit more on a time
schedule the first one I would be like
leafy you're just when I'm like it's
fine everyone's alive it's all good
three months after baby boy Demetri
arrived and mom of two Mila Kunis is
looking amazing but she admits when it
comes to parenting the struggle is real
we feel like we're being suffocated by
like plastic with like toys and diapers
and thing I mean it's crazy and while it
is the greatest thing in the world do
you ever look around and be like gosh we
used to be the cool kids yes all the
time
really cool and clean like our house
used to be like nice and modern and
pristine like that all goes out the
windows I can do a kid the 33 year old
is at the Las Vegas movie convention
CinemaCon promoting bad mom's Christmas
but the big question is will the
Kutcher's go for baby number three three
nope no no we're good on to right now
we're solid it's perfect it's like great
you know I have two really healthy
really wonderful kids why why test my
luck
[Music]
you